[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody welcome back at 6 42 of
monica jackson and it's time for mondays
with monica so
you all know this especially parents
covet 19 has really touched all
aspects of our lives even the
entertainment industry right we're the
entertainment capital of the world so
joining me live via zoom this morning is
cindy blackman santana
yeah santana she's a virtuoso
drummer band leader musician this woman
is something else and yes
carlos santana is her husband you know
cindy everybody's going to ask that how
are you this morning thank you for
joining us i'm doing so
great how are you doing and thanks for
having me absolutely loving that afro by
the way
love it all right hey let's talk about
you know um
cindy i i've known you for a little
while so i gotta act like i don't know
all about you but
you really are uh a savant when it comes
to drumming
i know you've been drumming since you
were a toddler you got your first
music or a drum set when you were seven
years old talk to parents about
helping their children get through this
keeping their chops
sharp during this pandemic because even
the kiddos are stressed out
they are stressed it's really a shame
because you know they're used to being
able to
to to go out and to do things you know
so it's really important right now for
parents to really feed
you know all of the creative desires
of their children in terms of the arts
and athletics
you know to keep their minds focused to
keep their bodies in tune
you know to keep their energies you know
um
high so that they're burning so they're
not just sitting around fidgeting and
you know
becoming mischievous so you know for me
music is one of the best ways to do that
and drumming is an incredible way to do
that because it involves
so much of everything in terms of the
mental focus the emotion
and also the physical you know aspect of
it so
you know it's really important uh for
parents to hone in
and really really provide
uh us you know things for the children
to do yeah and you know you can do those
things at home a lot of parents don't
want to hear drums but you can get drum
pads
you know and you can you can work it out
so that they have
access to to really you know channeling
the energies that they all have
i'm glad you said that because i'm like
uh you know i have a 14 year old son and
there's no way he's going to be drumming
in the house it's loud i'm already
stressed out so there are
you know different types of i guess
tools so to speak
that can keep them moving keep their
mind sharp but keep quiet in the house
as well
exactly there are a lot of things and
and athletically there are a lot of
things you know a jump rope
okay is like a godsend you know a jump
rope
um you can you can jump for three
minutes
okay and it's like running a mile you
know and and that's pretty quiet
and it's pretty easy to carry around you
can carry i carry that around in my bag
yeah you know um so there are a lot of
like you say tools i love that word
that you know you can use for children
and for for the adults too we need to
release as well
yeah absolutely how many times a week
cindy i know you practice all the time
whenever i call you you're in the studio
but
how many times a week right now should
the kids be practicing and again it's a
mental thing i used to play a clarinet i
can still play mary had a little lamb
but i'm sure you don't want to hear it
how many times a week should the kids be
practicing
as much as possible you know it's like
you know if they can do
um half an hour a day
you know for a child a half an hour a
day five days a week or
three or four days a week i think it
will really help and if you can get your
child to do
something every day whether it's playing
their instrument
if you can get them engaged yeah you
know that will really help
and they don't you know for me you know
to have a child
um watching the goings-on
every single minute you know i don't
think that's that's healthy let them let
them
understand what's happening so that
they're careful yeah safe
but keep them engaged in activities that
like i said before really spur
the the creativity and the physicality
because they have a lot of energy
yeah my nieces and nephews they just go
and go and go and go and go so you know
i find that my siblings have to
really find things to keep them engaged
absolutely okay i got 30 seconds
i want to give the drummer some i love
that new cd you collaborated with your
hubster
and you collaborated with a whole bunch
of other musicians how
fun was that what's your favorite track
on the new cd tell us where we can get
it as well
you can get it everywhere it's streaming
you know you can get it um on
on uh all of all of the itunes and all
the streaming channels
and you know my favorite track probably
is
imagine we did a cover of the john
lennon song imagine everything else is
original
but it was so amazing because it's got
carlos santana john mclaughlin
um uh curt hammett vernon reed and and
many other people a lot of songs a lot
of emotion
and some great messages i love it cindy
i could talk to you forever but i'm out
of time thank you
so much we got to get together once
covert is over have lunch again okay my
friend
i look forward to that girl all right
say hello to the hubster for me thank
you so much
absolutely he already said hi all right
all right folks hey again catch me right
here on channel eight for mondays with
monica every monday during the six
o'clock
hour